in this capsule we will be reducing the
problem of computer vision
the purpose of this part of the course
it is to explore the b to ba of vision
by computer
we're going to talk about operettas
simple ones that you can
apply on images found
often in vision systems by
computer such as detection
outline or the calculation of what we
calls image gradients and
finally see an application that of
object recognition which is a
possible tasks in vision by
computer that will require between
others feature extraction
useful from the game but the woody
on what are called histograms of
gradient let's start more for by one
motivation of the interest of the vision by
computer artificial intelligence
In fact, it is likely that little
near all creatures and and rims
already have vision so they have
the ability to interpret from
information related to the view for for
watch pursued so actually on
can easily imagine that it's a
sense actually the vision that is very
helpful to the survival of an organism that
brings a lot of information about his
environment know where is the
food where the predators are
institude so without much surprise if
for example, we look at the human being
makes 25% of the brain about all that
this measurement is in town from a source to
the other but around 25% of the brain's
the capacity finally the number of
neurons we have in connections
in the brain but 1% is either dedicated to
auxerre at least to the vision in the being
human
if we compare with other senses like
louis or the touch is much more
down around 8 3% so already that shows to
what a sense it is of a capacity
which is very useful for a being
smart then it also gives a
idea of ​​the complexity in fact of the
task the complexity of making networks
vision tasks with a computer
in practice we are already going a lot
application of vision by
computer a first is what we
calls character recognition
so I give an image like this here in
input from a computer and I wish
determine which character has
been written either by a person or
maybe print characters which this
here we have this system called the
net 5 which was developed by
researchers who are on task and
landings
in fact it comes from the work of
yann that one of his colleagues who puts
nokia world that amazes me father city of
new york is actually the system that
was developed here which is based on this
called neural networks to
convolution were deployed there to
united states to read checks
several checks in the systems
bank in the united states
the application knows it's the detection of
faces again here we have an image you
pull brien jobs from none
so and several different approaches
for face detection and that's
something that we find more and
more in the phones if he has
this ability to take a picture
then identify where the
people and specifically where is
their faces so that it started from
the tool the convoy in everyone's life
the days that is usable in life
everyday, too, you can
do image search so
google among others bones his system his
search engine that takes input
have no written request but a
image query so we can give here
an image or a system of google images
and then came the hour turns and others
images on the web that are similar to
we can also do that there are
tools to do that in our own
collections of sound photos were found
the different pictures of a person
we only have one hand and
that we would like from then all
pictures of that same person there so he
has more and more in the last
years have seen a lot of progress in
the ability to interpret an image
like that can find other images
which were semantically the hymen
that contain the same person the same
landscape so on
and finally we can do the vision
by computer on video
in this case it is an application of
tracking objects that shows here so we
has a video ie a sequence
image finally distributed in the
time and at any time so for each
picture of each given moment we are
identified in this case also in this
example here where are the players
soccer in a on a field so
a utility on it could be for
do an analysis automate the
strategy of different teams by
example I do not come here to the video in
as it is on youtube
which you will see as
as the video unfolds we see
that the rectangles here that identifies the
position of the different players
move a follow anyway enough
well the shape of the players on the ground
about examples of applications of
computer vision in this part
short of it we will really focus
on the country addresses the foundations of the
computer vision that are often
mentioned in in various
computer vision applications
we'll start with you comment on this
how do we manipulate images how do we
represents them and what kind of meadow
basic treatment are useful in the
development of an application in
computer vision is really
the goal here is first rather
an overview of approaches are
followed in computer vision have so
talked about other tools that are
frequently used as a notion of
correlation convolution the notion of
gradients of an image is also
the option of two guardian histograms
which is a way of extra a
new representation of an image that
is more useful for solving
different problems in vision by
computer including there recognition
of objects that we will talk a little